russia warning ukrainian citizens in
keeve to flee their homes as they begin
ramping up shelling
let's turn to foreign correspondent trey
yinks live in kiev
now for the latest on the ground trey
jesse good evening ukrainian president
velodemir zielinski speaking out tonight
from a bomb shelter in kiev and he
talked about a variety of things giving
us some new insight into the mind of a
man who's pledged to stay and fight he
talked about the bombing campaign
against his city and his country
basically saying there will be no peace
talks that are successful until that
campaign stops he also talked about nato
and the possibility of a no-fly zone
over this country and he added that he
does have an open line with the united
states via a satellite phone that he was
given reportedly by president biden and
his team in washington he had this to
say about the commander-in-chief
i talked to president biden many times i
am very grateful to him for all the
opportunities and the support but they
did not hear me i told them that ukraine
will fight we'll fight more than anyone
else but we just by ourselves left alone
against russia we simply cannot manage
the ukrainian capital of kiev was hit
multiple times today with russian
attacks a tv tower used for
communication was also targeted killing
five people this evening we've heard
shelling in the distance and some
gunfire this all comes as the streets of
this capital city are locked down every
block has a new checkpoint with soldiers
or civilians who have volunteered to
fight jesse trey your understanding of
the president zielinski
you think he'd die for his country if
they lay siege at the capitol you think
he'd go down
shooting
i do he's surrounded right now by men
with weapons they have a variety of
bunkers set up across the city and he's
been given multiple opportunities to
leave this country and it's a similar
sentiment that we've seen from other top
officials in this capital of kiev
members of parliament going to police
stations and picking up weapons
preparing ammunition and saying they
will stay in the city these are people
who have the resources to leave they
could flee they could go to the united
states if they wanted to they have the
connections they have the contacts and
the money but they're choosing to stay
and defend their country jesse all right
a lot different than afghanistan i'll
tell you that thank you so much trey hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else